um there are new reports that Donald
Trump is regularly not coming into work
until noon and that he is raged watching
five to seven hours of television every
morning and my feelings about this are
sort of mixed and I'll tell you why do
we want Trump doing more work in the
sense that when Trump works he's mostly
doing bad things he's incompetent he's
hurting people he's hurting the country
the more that he works we'll discuss
that in a moment the report is that
Katie Rogers and Annie Carney a say at
the New York Times that during
coronavirus Trump has this routine that
he's sort of gotten into that he's often
showing up to the Oval Office around
noon or later he's typically in a
terrible mood from all of the TV he's
been watching all morning it starts as
early as 5:00 a.m. with Fox News he
watches CNN he's watching MSNBC we know
this is true because he often tweets
about CNN or about Morning Joe on MSNBC
at exactly those times and it seems to
fire him up even more and he's showing
up to work very very upset Trump will
also as he's watching TV for five to
seven hours every morning he'll get on
the phone with advisors and complain to
them about how he's not being portrayed
as a great savior when it comes to
coronavirus and what we have also
learned from this article in The New
York Times excellent article is that the
nightly press briefings that Trump has
been doing most evenings are basically
the only thing he has to look forward to
and that actually explains a lot and
sheds a ton of light on to the question
of we've been wondering why is he doing
these press briefings almost constantly
every single one sees him digging
himself into a deeper and deeper hole
culminating Thursday with wondering
aloud about injecting bleach and
isopropyl alcohol he's not helping
himself he's arguably hurting himself
and indeed it seems as though the reason
he's doing it is because it's all that
he has going on and indeed when you look
at Donald Trump's calendar it matches up
with this reporting yesterday for
example Donald Trump's first scheduled
thing was 2 p.m. and it was just a
conference call last Friday similar
Trump had nothing on his calendar before
noon when he signed a bill and then you
have his defenders like for example the
new press secretary Kaley McKenna knee
she pops up and she defends Trump and
says it's all fake news and they always
go too far in the defense's like if she
put out there a sort of realistic
defense of Trump's work ethic and
schedule it might be believable but she
goes way too far he or she says Trump is
working so much that he sometimes
forgets to eat mark Meadows was asked
about what his concern is day-to-day as
he looks at the president's schedule and
he made the point that the president is
so busy and so hard at work you know his
concern is making sure he gets a bite to
eat here and there so you know you've
got to put that into context first of
all of course we are concerned for
America's workers so obviously we know
that's not true obviously Donald Trump
is not forgetting to eat he is likely
technically obese if we evaluate what we
believe is actual weight is there's no
indication whatever that he's missing
meals unless he is actually on uppers as
some people suspect and uppers tend to
take away your appetite but usually
you're making up for it by binging later
in the day once you've come down from
the uppers so it just it's not it's too
much it's not believable the report that
Trump isn't coming in till noon and
barely working seems to be well sourced
to then come back and say Trump works
harder than anyone and is sometimes
forgetting to eat it's too much and it's
not believable and that gets us to the
practical question do we want Trump
working this was a question before the
coronavirus Fiasco before the corona
virus pandemic where we would talk about
Trump's golf trips Trump to date has
golfed 264 days during his presidency
and that is a sign of an incredibly lazy
person with a poor work ethic but at the
same time do we want Trump working when
he does terrible things when he actually
works we talked about testing earlier
today Trump should have built a proper
testing apparatus for coronavirus he
should have built a proper contact
tracing apparatus for coronavirus but
would he have gotten it done if he came
into work at 10:00 a.m. instead of noon
or would he simply have done other
things that would have been bad I don't
know what I can tell you is I've never
watched seven hours of TV and
in my life maybe if I was like homesick
I watched five hours maybe like a couple
times in my life I can't remember this
guy is the president and he has time for
five to seven hours of television a day
he often tweets dozens of times a day he
sometimes gotten close to a hundred
tweets and retweets in a single day I
just run a little independent show with
a few employees and I don't nearly have
the time for this this guy is the
president so it's bizarre but I want to
hear your reaction do we really want
Trump working more given that the more
he does the more bad things he's doing
let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman there's a YouTube
channel called up flip that we're
partnering with I would love for you to
check it out I've put the link right
underneath the video make sure to
subscribe to the channel when you're
there up flip is a channel that is all
about exploring small business and what
makes a small business successful every
episode interviews an entrepreneur you
take a tour of the business and these
are not generic interviews you actually
get a really fascinating deep dive into
the history of the business the mistakes
the entrepreneur made what they learned
what motivates them what a day is like
running their business and you get all
sorts of super interesting and valuable
insight about what it's like to run that
type of small business as a business
owner myself I find up flips videos to
be endlessly intriguing even if you
don't own your own business it is really
great for a general audience it's stuff
that I think just about anybody would
find fascinating and you can check it
out by going to david pakman.com slash
up flip the link is right underneath
this video when you're there make sure
to subscribe and click the bell for
notifications